[Music]
okay I really like this thing where I'm
like showing you a photo you guys have
to guess okay yeah let's do it
we got a good imagination don't break
here's a photo tell me what's the story
that is my mom that baby looks like what
the [ __ ] mom what's the story oh they're
gonna recreate it I like those this is a
baby that looks like mom but he was
actually adopted
oh that's Andrew yang when he was a baby
you're getting worn with the word
adopted baby doesn't wanna be
photographed the baby adopted the mom
yes no oh this lady went to an adoption
agency adopted the baby come to find out
it's her real baby that she gave up for
adoption earlier in her life but no damn
damn no dog did his baby they fell in
love
oh no no no sweet but that baby looks
like her baby yeah he got the same nose
and eyes and so you guys are correct
that this is mother and child okay okay
well he don't like the picture though
well what ended up happening is back in
1988 when this little boy was 2 years
old
uh-huh before they had color cameras
they had color cameras back then this
guy was just going for the vintage wood
yeah so this little boy he was with his
dad and they for some reason we're like
in a hotel I think passing by and then
the little boy asked his dad like oh can
I get some water I'm really thirsty and
so the dad went to go find him some
water and it was hot water so it was
like cooling it down putting it like in
another club for like a split second he
wasn't looking at the kid and that's
when he got abducted Oh somebody stole
the baby yeah someone stole oh my god he
is a cute baby he's kind of stealable
well he's cute but with a face like that
he looks kind of grumpy though yeah you
look for your old man kinda yeah yeah
I wouldn't leave a two-year-old by
himself maybe a three-year-old but not
two yeah you're right my mother left me
when I was three we were at Circus
Circus III is fine yeah so you know in
the in the front they have like those
like sweepstakes sign up for this we
could win this car or whatever so she
was like oh shoot like I think my dad
was somewhere else and then she was like
I gotta go buy a tickets to the circus
show so she just put me on the boat for
the sweepstakes team she's like just
stay here and as she left and that's
when the cops came and then they saw me
and they took me into the police station
and I was crying my eyes out cuz I could
have swore that I was there obviously my
parents are free and they handcuffed me
to the chair inside the police station
I'll run away and then finally my mom
found me on even ah she found me yes
ma'am
did they have like nice cuffs for kids
yeah speaking that yeah it was big and
scary those are for kids
I know they're not freakin great ones
are not for kids okay just a good
tip-out they're pink and furry not for
kids so anyway so back to the story so
for the last 32 years this these parents
have been like tirelessly looking I
would've gave up after six months 30
years hard work that's like trying to
find treasure in the [ __ ] Caribbean
ocean without a man I know right yeah so
the mom she ended up becoming a
volunteer at a major non-governmental
platform called baby come home that
tracks down kidnap children and she has
helped more than 20 families find their
missing children
oh hell yeah which is probably better
just to find her own like she had hoped
that like she never ever obviously gave
up hope that she would one day find her
son and then just recently she did she
found her son because there was this
anonymous tip about like this boy that
was so because I throughout all these
years she kept following leaves and I
think it was like 300 leads like 300
leads over the last 32 years that she
had been following to see if these kids
that like rumored like oh so and so
about this kid or what
and then like that's how she was able to
help reunite a lot of families but so
that's when because of this tip she
found out that her son had been sold to
a childless couple for six thousand yuan
which is about eight hundred and forty
five dollars in today's money whoa so
this is a Chinese children market that's
crazy
that'll cost less than a Bitcoin maybe
that's a lot of money out there it was
underground like adoption agencies
like you think you think when a kid gets
kidnapped it's like you're sex trap well
like sex trafficking or like you know
slate like the sweatshops you can do
like the the organs and [ __ ] I am [ __ ]
up I thought that just like in rural
areas too they'll be like hey you want a
kid all right we need some farm help and
it get kids right maybe it's one of
those situations like we can't have kids
have you went to an adoption agency it's
too expensive
well I got a right over here yeah I mean
yeah that's it seems like that's why
they're kidnapping kids to sell them and
[ __ ] you want a discount kid what if
you're in the market for Katie you're in
luck just snatched up a little fresh
little two-year-old Asian right you know
right yeah all right
they'll be like in the [ __ ] alleys of
Shanghai baby with that [ __ ] strap
thing on baby but yeah so this has been
huge huge major news in China their
reunion you know what's crazy have you
seen those pictures oh they're in the
Great Depression they have there's like
a woman with kids and it's like free
kids or they're like selling their own
kids and [ __ ] because they couldn't feed
their kids yeah and that's here it feels
like it's so foreign
yeah so I'm gonna show you guys the
reunion video it's really heartwarming
okay okay would you even remember though
that's - I don't remember [ __ ] man I
remember one time that's it one little
thing I would remember from being 2
years old I might have like two memories
from three maybe and then maybe a little
bit more for remember crying on a bed
that's all
memory I know you were too though oh
because it was my birthday well I was
turning to and I remember the cake I
have memories of being in my mother's
womb I used her eyes I have the right to
make that joke by the way not a lot of
people do don't know it's just him not
making fun of people it's you know his
own people yeah that's right that's true
oh [ __ ] you guys yeah it's a crazy like
be like all these years so the thing
that I really really really want to know
is like what's going on with the
adoptive parents who did they buy this
kid from you have a good life yeah did
he have a good life what if he had a
better life there I know he's like I
wanna go back yeah he's like the water's
always lukewarm at my new she starts
living at his new place and he's like
Luke I don't like this very much I don't
like it so the only thing I do know
about this guy now is that he owns an
interior design business that's it oh
and then like the mom was like because
she was holding on tight to his hand
like this that this whole like reunion
and was he like my arm can't breathe
like they're being interviewed at
something she was like like I can't like
he can't leave me again like no like you
can't I can't just don't put them down
anywhere 34 year old man but I don't
know I'm like Dan that's easy imagine
being in that situation you're 34 years
old you've already lived your whole life
like you know up until then you have
your business that you're running I'm
not sure if he has his own family and
stuff but you have a whole life and then
next thing you know you reunite with
your long-lost parents and there
they have been searching for you for 32
years like never giving up always hoping
you would come home and now you get
reunited like imagine the pressure for
that kid to not leave him and like go
back to his own life I wonder at what
point he found out that his parents
weren't his real parents though right
because that hug looked like he missed
them I would have run up and hug I was
like I don't know like that's kind of
weird so he had to have found out you
know yeah where he remembered unless the
producers relay hey when I open this
doghouse I love a lot of feelings like
we got to do it again that was [ __ ]
the very beginning he was like this
that's not going viral I'll never go
viral
can you just do this and embrace them
embrace come right out and then it's
like it's like okay here he hits the
door with his head he's like okay I mean
but yeah I mean probably because of the
entire put like media circus is there so
me really felt like that like for him
probably like that needs embrace him
okay and you have to hold for at least
two minutes man he's not motivating it
what can you haven't seen it for 30
years this is something yeah what was my
motivation tell me please when you get
there you embrace her yours but I don't
even know this woman
okay
they did a 24 in me because it's the
Chinese version
what's 24 in a person okay and me 24 and
me yeah versus honey I mean you are so
so hot wall doesn't really fall off the
touch it flows right fine you parents
versus a hen with no yeah they did they
said that they they have been able to
what is the statistics here they said in
2016 the ministry launched reunion an
online tracking system that helped find
4385
of the
thousand four hundred and sixty-seven
reported missing children that's really
good I want to start an organization
like that and call it what about the
children children yeah what about the
children
is that the one we're doing together no
no for us we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna do pedophile hunters oh that is a
different that is a citizen you're right
thank you I thought we're gonna do
coyote hunters that's different that's
different okay there's a lot of business
I'm gonna have a lot of organizations
like a lot okay well there's that one
that's legit we saw it the Tony Robbins
seminar it's called like underground
underground railroad was it yeah but
it's it's [ __ ] sick so this
organization all these like like retired
or you know current active military
police investigator CIA FBI all these
like top-notch dudes they have this
group where they find like kids who are
dubbed a abducted abducted in child sex
slavery stream and they come in and
[ __ ] SWAT gear and [ __ ] like [ __ ]
that's tight yeah um actually Kutcher's
involves something like that and also
there's this app that that if you go to
hotels that they encourage people to
download this app and then take photos
we talked about take photos of kids no
take photos of your room so then they
can't like the room number which hotel
you're in like the city and all that
[ __ ] of that exact room so then they
like cross-reference through all the
[ __ ] that's like the old like the
Cape Horn and a real porn well so when
they see an environment behind the kid
they know where it is
holy [ __ ] yeah a whole [ __ ] I forgot
what a database
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]